the bbc has been publicly and furiously
excoriated by the heir to the throne
and is being warned by ministers that
they will intervene if it doesn't do
enough to restore
trust with the public we did ask the bbc
to appear on this program but they have
chosen not to
so let's bring in dorothy byrne former
head of news and current affairs
at channel 4. dorothy burn you were one
of the
most senior executives in british tv
journalism at channel 4 for many years
and in fact it was channel 4's
documentary uh last october that started
questions being asked about this whole
affair once again
how serious is this for the corporation
do you think and can it recover
i think it's extremely serious what has
been revealed
is absolutely scandalous
and it is scandalous that for more than
25 years the bbc has refused to
fess up to what it did when in fact
all other television journalists have
known
about the faking of these um bank
statements
for more than a quarter of a century
it's also scandalous
that martin bashir was employed just a
few years ago
ironically as head of religion so it is
extremely serious
and actually we as other television
journalists
are outraged because it has
led some people to smear the whole of
our profession
when in fact television journalism
overwhelmingly
is very tightly regulated
and not at all the way that tabloid
journalism
behaves since the events 26 years ago
the bbc has become regulated
independently
and i think that is absolutely key
uh at the time the bbc was permitted to
regulate itself which was clearly
absolutely wrong so i think it's very
serious but we shouldn't see
this as an opportunity to attack
all television journalism however i do
think that the bbc itv
and us networks need to look
at all the other stories which martin
bashir did
many things
sorry say that again you're saying we
need to go back
over martin bashir's record through
bbc he's worked for itv i think he may
have worked for channel 4
and a couple of the new us networks and
we need to look at
all he's done yes i
do not believe martin bashir ever worked
for channel 4 i would never have
employed martin
bashir i knew all about him many
questions well i didn't know all about
him i knew some about him
many knew enough about him to say that
if if if he'd come to you for a job
you would have shown him the door he
wouldn't even have got to the door
he's one of the most notorious
journalists in britain
and has been for a quarter of a century
i mean
it would be almost funny that the bbc
had employed him as head of religion if
it wasn't
so obscene but other people who
have been interviewed by michael by
um martin bashir have complained
that he lied to them and
we know that the bbc wrote a formal
letter to
itv about martin bashir's conduct
on several stories so i think that
both bbc and itv need to look at all his
scoops
because what martin bashir and some of
those around him
did was mistake getting a scoop at all
costs for proper decent ethical
journalism
doris let me put this to you um
you are pretty uh robust about
martin bashir's record martin bashir
might say
if he were watching this well of course
they'd say that
they didn't get the story so of course
they're going to try to bury me
martin bashir can say that if he wants
i would rather not have a story
than get a story by lying
proper investigative journalism
should never be confused
with lying to get a scoop a scoop is not
the be-all and end-all of journalism
that's i if i may say a terribly male
attitude towards journalism you know
journalism is about
careful and forensic investigation
of the type that we saw in the panorama
uh last week which exposed
martin bashir i i
yes one looked at that interview and
thought it's amazing that he got that
interview
but that's actually one of the problems
with martin bashir
on several occasions other journalists
have thought
how on earth did he get that scoop how
on earth did he persuade that person to
do that interview
and that is what we must now
see investigated dorothy
this story is really just uh in part
about
martin bashir the bigger issue i guess
is about the bbc
do you think the time has come for the
bbc to stop
being able to mark its own homework
well the bbc no longer marks its own
homework
in the way that it did more than 25
years ago
it's now properly regulated by ofcom
and i think that ofcom is a good
regulator
and from all over the world people come
to the united kingdom
to look at our system of regulation
because it is so good and it's because
it's so
good that we have very high levels
of trust in british television
journalism and particularly
during this pandemic we've seen
ofcom itself has revealed these figures
very high even higher than usual
levels of trust in television journalism
so we we mustn't assume
that the public doesn't trust
journalists
it is worth pointing out though that
those very of com figures that you're
quoting
put uh the bbc at the bottom of the
trust league
uh 10 points behind sky eight point
behind your own channel
four do you think that
this system of regulation though
has been shown to be at best
inadequate do you give any credence to
the proposals
for example from lord gray that there
should be uh
an editorial board of experienced
journalists
who can spot the signs of this kind of
thing going on which
you know the bbc's board of governors
the best will in the world full of
people who don't do journalism
would never be able to see
at the time that this happened the bbc
was regulating itself it is now
quite recently moved to a new system
where it is regulated in the same way
that the rest of us are
the idea that yet another committee
of so-called experienced blokes is going
to
make some difference i i don't have
any i don't give much credit to the idea
that the problem with men is more men
i i think that the regulator that we now
have
is good i do think that one reason
that the bbc has fallen
just slightly in these tables of trusts
is the relentless attack on it in
newspapers
which i think would affect people's
attitudes towards it
but i've never worked for the bbc i've
never wanted to work for the bbc
i've always regarded it as an arrogant
organization of post-white blokes
and that's what we saw happen in that
um in this scandal how
those men covered the traces
but it is a very good organization
and the journalists are good you you you
will
be familiar with the uh phrase
that it's not the crime that's that
really killed you but it's the cover-up
and i wonder your equivalent
uh at the bbc who later became
director general tony hall
did what dyson has described as a pretty
weak and feeble investigation
what do you imagine was going through
the minds of bbc
management when they allowed this to
happen
how could do you think having been at
that level of responsibility
how do you think this actually took
place
i cannot see into the mind of that man
i think there is a great arrogance there
isn't there in that institution
certainly at the time
that they thought they didn't need to be
transparent
you know there's a moment when you
discover something bad has happened in
your organization
and you need to gird your loins and
and face up to it it's happened to me in
my career that
bad things have happened in the
organization and
what you have to do is admit it
there's an arrogance about the fact that
the bbc
didn't admit it at the time and i think
that was partly the culture and that
there were
too many similar types of people
overwhelmingly men running that
organization
and it shows me that we need greater
diversity
in the higher management of
organizations in our country
the bbc's got a new boss tim davey who
was responsible for
publishing this dyson report um what
would he
need to do to satisfy you that the bbc
has done enough
to make sure that nothing like this uh
and i include the cover-up by the way
could happen
again for me
it's important that the bbc
should also inquire into how
martin bashir ever came to be
the head of religion and it's important
to me that they should look at the other
stories that he did at the bbc
and they should cooperate fully with
ofcom
when they receive complaints i think
they do
they do behave better now indeed i
recently made a complaint
tim davey myself about the bbc and he
responded
wow uh well i bet he's uh pretty
terrified after this
thank you very much dorothy burton thank
you